I want to get this content out there
because I want to help people I
genuinely do I'm like this needs to be
heard but I'm like listen the delivery
is going to be rough every time
something comes up of like oh you don't
look good today oh this isn't off oh the
lighting oh that I just tell myself oh
your brain is trying to keep you safe
because it doesn't like making content
because it's uncomfortable so just like
come up and just go do it anyways right
hey welcome to the think media podcast
my name is Heather Torres the host of
this show where we want to help you
build your influence on YouTube and then
turn that influence into a high income
and a high profit online business and I
am so excited about today's episode we
actually have made it into a two-parter
for you because this guest had some
power packed information for you some
really great takeaways so I wanted to
bring you the best of this in two
different parts today I'm excited
because we have none other than Layla
hermosi here on the show but before I
get into that I want to let you know
that today's episode is brought to you
by 21 video tips if you like content
like this where you can go deeper in
learning the best video strategies that
are working for top influencers right
now then go to 21videotips.com get that
free download and free master class so
that you have all of the most valuable
information that's working right now
well if you're not familiar with who
Leila hermosi is her and her husband
Alex built gym launch in just 20 months
from zero to 50 million dollars they
have since sold that in their other
companies and they are now on a mission
to help entrepreneurs build their
businesses and they do this through
their current company acquisition.com
but in the last almost two years Layla
has decided to get in front of the
camera and start sharing her knowledge I
am one of those benefactors of her
knowledge being shared and I'm so
excited to bring this woman to the
podcast she is a Powerhouse she has so
much knowledge but in this episode we're
really pulling back the curtain on Layla
the content creator and she's going to
be sharing with you uh her content
strategy how a busy entrepreneur is
coming up with content the way she's
going about starting and scaling her
team and the mistake that most
entrepreneurs make when they start
hiring for their content Team all of
that and more is happening in part one
so lean in and let's get started
so Leila you are an extraordinary
entrepreneur you are someone who has 10x
businesses you're making a huge impact
and waving the entrepreneurial community
and now you are now Layla the content
creator how do you feel about that I
don't identify as a content creator but
I I am happy to help in any way because
I think uh making content was something
I've procrastinated for a very long time
because it was never necessary for any
of my businesses so
um it had to come out of a desire to do
it rather than a fear of anything
because there was really no fear because
my business is all in the past made
money without making content so it is
new for me um I've only been doing it
now I think for 13 months yeah so 13
months and you really skyrocketed I mean
you and your husband Alex are really
kind of like the newest like gurus on
entrepreneurship basically because
you're just teaching what you know right
and I think that is one thing I really
want to touch on when we're going
through this but in 13 months how did
you have to go about finding your voice
on YouTube on tick tock on all the the
platforms that you're on but like how do
you figure out who Layla was as a
content creator yeah that's a really
good question I think that a lot of
people wait and this is a conversation I
was actually just having with Caleb like
they wait to like find their voice find
their brand and then I'll make content
right
um and I know by building a business the
practices of building a business are
you're not going to learn how to build a
business so you go freaking build a
business right and so the same goes for
Content so I literally I was at Bear
Lake I was there with Alex and I
remember I woke up one morning at like
4am and I was sitting there and I was
thinking like oh today is actually a day
and this is mid-selling our other
businesses that we've now sold
um or I didn't have like a ton on my
calendar and I had the thought in the
back of my mind always lingering like
you should make content like you know
you should make content and Alex had
bought a bunch of stuff to bring to Bear
Lake to make content and I woke up and I
don't know what it was I just got so fed
up with myself that I was like just go f
and make it like you don't have perfect
conditions I don't have my outfits and
all my hair stuff I don't have anything
right I was like just go make it and so
that day I made my first three videos
ever and they were awful
um and and what I realized was I just
have to continue to make them in order
to you know move forward and actually be
a content creator and so what I I figure
it's the same as business which is at
first you suck then you suck a little
less and a little less and eventually
one day you're good and then eventually
you actually get really good and so
that's what I feel the process has been
in terms of finding my voice it's
it's not even finding my voice Heather
it's
uncovering my voice because a lot of the
times people act differently in front of
a camera yeah and so like my goal is
like I already know who I am I run this
business I am the CEO I am this person I
already do all these things I already
know who I am it's just like how do I
become more comfortable in front of a
camera in front of YouTube in front of a
live audience to reveal that that's what
I think it really is more so and so
that's been what the journey has been is
how can I be my authentic self in front
of a camera and the more that I detach
myself from the outcome of the content
the more I'm able to do that yeah does
that make sense yeah definitely and I
noticed too
um even in your first couple videos
because I watch all of your videos I am
definitely your target audience
um I loved that you actually weren't
perfectly put together in a beautiful
Studio coming out like I loved that you
were just kind of like Layla and you
were just going through a slide
presentation and you were just you with
all the Eunice you know and and I want
to speak more to that for the new
entrepreneur coming online because you
as a CEO you as the person already in
that space case why why was that so
impactful at the beginning to do it that
way and not to do it like really waiting
yeah because I think here's the reality
is that plenty of people that I follow
and I just look at the people I follow
I'm like is Warren Buffett building a
YouTube studio right you know what I
mean like that's ridiculous yeah um and
so I kind of feel that way yeah it's
like I want to get this content out
there because I want to help people I
genuinely do I'm like this needs to be
heard but I'm like listen the delivery
is going to be rough until I get a team
because I just don't have time it's not
my first priority and the reason I'm
good at making content is because it's
not my first priority yeah it's because
it's my second or third priority yeah
right and so I think that people have to
put that into context I hope that
becomes more normalized because you know
now we're building a team and such so
things will be able to be more
production in terms of like I don't want
to ever take away the authenticity of
like who we are in the content but I
think things can be more appealing like
the lighting can be better you know the
camera's not shaking like things like
that that actually make it easier to
consume I'd like to do but I think a lot
of people ultimately like every time
something comes up of like oh you don't
look good today oh this isn't off oh the
lighting oh that I just tell myself like
oh your brain is trying to keep you safe
because it doesn't like making content
because it's uncomfortable so just like
shut up and just go do it anyways right
and so I think it's being able to make
those decisions value-based decisions
rather than fear-based decisions which
is like this is in line with who I want
to be in the values I have and so I will
do it despite if I feel uncomfortable or
nervous so don't feel like doing it that
day like I'm still gonna do it oh so
good so liberating too when you think
about that I never thought about that
Warren Buffett is not trying to build a
YouTube studio so why are we trying to
make it always so perfect and I think
that's really what draws the audience in
now how did you figure out who you
wanted to speak to because you have done
a lot of different things right I mean
you've built successful businesses and
sold them you started acquisition.com is
it was it a an actual strategy to say I
want to talk to this person because that
will help us do this thing or did you
just know who you wanted to talk to the
beginning
I I don't think I even know still really
who I'm talking to no
um I think I have a general idea now of
who I'm talking to but the people that I
want to reach and want to help I think
are a little more rare than typical
right and so I'm finding like the
different buckets of what I like to talk
to say it's two things which is like
CEOs and CEOs who want to grow and scale
their businesses like they just want no
BS like tell me what to do I'm gonna go
do it like and I can just give you like
I love dishing out the tactics right the
second is probably actually employees
employees who want to grow in their
career maybe they want to start a
business maybe they want to figure out
how to get to an executive level because
I genuinely love doing that in my
business therefore why would I not make
content on it and that's something I've
recently discovered so I'm like oh I
love talking to people that are working
in the business I would like to help
more and I would love to have videos
that won the CEOs and operators can take
and they can learn themselves and then
two they can share them with their team
and be like go watch this this is how
we're gonna promote this is how you can
grow in your career like that's the
stuff I really like doing so I think I
just think about who do I like talking
to on a day-to-day pieces so like if
you're an entrepreneur and you're
watching this you know video I think I
would be thinking to myself like who do
you already talk to naturally that's
probably who your audience is so like
Alex for example naturally his friends
who he surrounds himself with Etc
they're usually marketing based CEOs or
you know sales uh centered CEOs or
people that are faces of the brand
that's who he's always liked talking to
so like why wouldn't that be his content
you know what I mean and so for me I'm
like oh these are the people I already
like talking to so that makes sense I
would make content for them because one
I've been there slash I am there and
then third it's already what I do so I
already know it yeah yeah oh so good
you're busy though I mean I watched a
video recently you're working 14 hours a
day which I I also want to talk about
the feedback on that video because I
thought it was very interesting
um some of the feedback but you are in
it all the time meaning you are in your
business all the time how are you coming
up with content what are some tips you
have for other you know entrepreneurs
who are trying to make content while
also running a business yeah I mean I
think it comes down to this which is you
could also want to run your business and
have a family you could also want to run
your business and find a wife or a
husband I there's always going to be
competing priorities and so it's just a
matter of understanding that in periods
of time where you want to grow something
else you have to sacrifice something
which is usually like your leisurely
time so for me like that for example
like this last weekend like I woke up I
had people in town but I woke up at 5am
and I from five to nine like busted out
content because I knew we were going to
be doing YouTube videos later in the
week I like to like script out and know
the points I want to hit for YouTube
um so I did that and so a lot of times
you know it's like the team preps ideas
of like this is like what we're thinking
here's some different headlines here's
some stuff that people wanted from other
videos and then that gets me enough to
be like okay I think I know what I want
to talk about
um but it's making the time you know
it's it's
rather than and I always it's like
everyone's while I'm getting in the
dumps I'm like Alex it's so much easier
just to run the company you know like
now I have to like make content I'm
speaking I'm doing all this stuff like
it's so much harder
um
it you have to remember why you're doing
it I think that's the most important
piece is that in anything in life it's
like if you're annoyed with your spouse
or you're annoyed with your kids it's
like like why are they there why did you
want to have kids why did you want to
have a spouse I think it's always
remembering and like connecting back to
that why and I always just remind myself
I'm like I want to be what I wish I had
had when I was building a business
therefore I will do these things even if
in the moment it's uncomfortable and I
don't want to do them yeah and so you
know making the time is easy when it's a
priority to you it's just like anything
else and if you're running a business I
think you're probably already good at
managing your time yeah it's just that
you probably make a lot of excuses as to
why it's not a priority because you're
like oh it doesn't generate Revenue yeah
it doesn't do these things yeah Etc it
can totally do that in the future though
and I think if anything like what I like
the most about it is that I've always
wanted to have a voice to potential
employees and now I have that out there
so it's very balanced versus you know we
had gym launch it was Alex who was the
face of in the ads and we didn't even do
organic content which is ADS
um so people knew that he was the owner
of the business but they didn't know
like I was actually like running most of
the business and so they would come in
and they were like oh I love Alex and
like they knew nothing about what I
thought my philosophy is like how I like
to run things yeah and so that was the
decision I wanted to make on many terms
because it can help people out there who
are trying to do what I've done and it
can also help attract the right kind of
talent to our business and so there are
a lot of benefits you just have to be
patient oh it's so good and are you
keeping a running list or like a journal
list for your own personal things where
you're like oh I was in that meeting
that was really good I should talk about
that or how do do you go about just kind
of involving your day-to-day into it
yeah I'm probably less like that like
Alex is much more like oh in the moment
let me write this down or I'm going to
tweet that I'm going to do that
um I'm much more I keep a list of ideas
but more often than not it's like once a
week when I do my setup on Sunday for
the rest of the week I'm like okay I
remember there were some ideas I had
about content what triggered those ideas
and I go back and I look at my calendar
I'm like cool I had that meeting where
this happened and I was like that would
make a good piece of content so I just
literally go back and look at my
calendar I'm like what did I do this
last week that I learned lessons from
that maybe reignited thoughts of old
lessons I've already learned maybe I was
training a CEO on something that I
thought would be valuable to other
people and so that's typically what I do
is I just go look at what I've already
been doing it's like garyvee says
document don't create and I think a lot
of people think that that means I should
have a camera guy following me around
all day while I'm eating cereal right
you know I'm gonna go viral right right
it's like that's boring [ __ ] like my day
to day I'm like sitting at a computer
like in sweatpants you know what I mean
like it's not that exciting but if I
document the things I have experienced
the lessons I have learned and the
epiphanies that could be utilized it's
almost like I'm filtering out the rest
that's not necessary and so it's like
I'm documenting the things that are
useful to the audience does that make
sense yeah totally and I I could see
that applying if you are real estate
agent if you are even if you're like a
chef or or anything that you're already
doing it's just taking those pieces and
sharing it with the audience knowing
exactly who you're talking to and
sharing it with that audience
um okay so uh I went back and saw some
of your videos and some of them people
are very upset with some of the things
you're saying how do you deal with
negative comments and this is kind of a
I would think in 13 months is kind of a
newer thing for you personally to
experience versus like uh negative
comments about your company so talk talk
about that a little bit
I absolutely expected to have a lot of
negativity because I also I told Alex as
I started making content I looked at him
and I was like I'm a little weird though
he was like what and I was like no like
I'm not like I love business I love
working all the time like I but I also
like love working out and I love doing
this like I'm there's a lot of like
contradiction in there and I was like I
don't think a lot of people are gonna
like me men specifically and he was like
probably not and I was like I'm prepared
um so I think it was like a conscious
decision in terms of I knew going into
it I was like I know who I am I know how
I present I know the things that I
already in public in person with people
rub people the wrong way so I'm like
that's gonna come out in the comments
for sure
um the way that I've dealt with it is a
couple things which is like you know in
the beginning there's definitely been
comments where like I've gotten it and
it's upset me you know like someone
makes a video making fun of you and you
see it when you're like at a party with
friends or like something like I
remember I was at a New Year's Eve party
and someone like sent me a video that
someone made like breaking down like me
and like the video and like they just
tore down everything about me how I
looked how I talked like the content it
was just awful and I remember I was like
who like I literally went to the
bathroom and I like I just sat there and
I was like who am I gonna beat I was
like am I gonna be that girl that like
let's
stranger tear her day apart or am I
going to be somebody who sets an example
for other women of how they can react to
the people that tear them apart and I I
really just believe that nothing has
more meaning than what you give to it
and so when someone comments something
about me or about the content that I'm
making
I don't take it personally it means
nothing about me and guess what it's
okay if they don't like me it's okay if
they don't agree with my content I don't
need to argue with them I don't need to
enter the situation and if anything
that's what people want is they want you
to enter the conversation with them I
have no interest in this conversation
nor do I have time for it and so I'm
like I'm busy building a business over
here if you want to troll on my [ __ ] all
day that's cool but like we wouldn't be
friends in real life so why would I
engage with you on YouTube and so that's
kind of how I look at it it's just
typically those people are insecure
they're you've said something that
provokes insecurity it contradicts the
belief they have I mean I'll watch
videos and be like oh I don't like that
guy and then I'm like why do I not like
the guy and I'm like oh he said
something that contradicts a belief I
have and then I'm like it's something I
don't like him it's like he says
something that agitated me right but a
lot of people don't have that level of
self-awareness they're just like I'm
gonna tell I'm gonna say bad things
about this person because on some level
they make me feel insecure or they they
contradict my world view
um I'm okay with that and I think it's
just like you have to accept that you
cannot stop it you cannot make it go
away if you try to make it go away it
won't like if you try to be someone else
it won't go away and if anything if you
try to be someone you're not so that you
can avoid negative comments I think at
the end of the day you're going to be
very dissatisfied because you're still
going to get them and now you're not
authentic so now you don't even like the
content you're putting out yeah and so I
kind of had a decision I made
I want to say it was like last it was
probably like three four months of
making content where I was like I can
either make content that's super vanilla
I I can go out there and listen this is
really the thought I have it's like I'm
a woman in business I like business I
like I'm like you know people are making
comments all day just like trashing me
and I'm like what am I gonna do like go
out there like put my tits out there
like you know put everything on blast
like show some skin like just like
really feminine then like people like me
and it's like that's normal because
that's more accepted for a woman to put
out than it is to talk about business
that's not who I am though right I've
never been that person when I was in
Fitness I wasn't that person like I wore
turtlenecks every day so like am I gonna
do that yeah no so I'm like okay what's
the other option then I'm myself and
people don't like me that's okay yeah
I'm totally fine with it because at the
end of the day I know who I am I know
who I want to be and the fact that
people don't like me that's been
something that I've dealt with my whole
life in person why can't I deal with it
online you know yeah so good and I think
I I mean I deal with that too because I
look at these amazing women who are you
know they wear heels and lots of makeup
and it's beautiful and I'm like I would
rather be in my camper or like out on a
hike with a backpack on you know those
types of things and same thing just have
to be authentic in whatever content
you're creating
um I love that you said that you get to
decide how you handle that and be the
example for other women and um I just
applaud you for that because I think
that is more of what we need in the
online space not less of it not more
attacking but actually more just like
going above it and saying I'm gonna be
me you can either like it or not so I
love that you said that
um I noticed actually that one of your
most popular reels right now is kind of
a behind the scenes of um your husband
and you where he says you just love to
like laugh randomly at things all the
time and I thought how interesting
usually the content you're making is
very business focused is isn't actually
behind the scenes we actually don't see
too much behind the scenes do you feel
like you're starting to get more
comfortable to share more of that side
of Layla with your audience yeah I think
that um I think that if anything it'll
probably make me more human because I
think you know like
if someone said this to me one time they
actually they met me and Alex and he was
like you guys are like really funny yeah
and I was like yeah yeah and he was like
why your content is so serious I was
like but I'm just talking about business
like you know that's not he's like I
think people would like to see you relax
and be funny and I was like huh
um so I think it's something that I
would like to work on I think that once
we have like an in-person office and we
have more of the team here like it'll be
easier to capture that stuff
um
like I wouldn't say it's like oh I'm
like I'm so for that stuff because like
I just you know
it's not it's like I'm like what this is
why I have a hard time with Heather is
like what value does that add to
someone's life but you know my beliefs
have been broken by people like Caleb in
terms of like that does add value to
people's lives to see that you're a
human yeah
um so I will do it if it's what is
required to add value to other people
that are watching and if that's what
they want to see
um now do I want to like tape every like
intimate moment with Alex no right you
know it's I still have a heart I am not
even the same wife and with Alex in
public in front of our team or in front
of like clients as I am in private so in
front of a camera there's no freaking
way it's not gonna work right um maybe
one day in like 20 years yeah but I
think um
yeah I think that was just you know
actually what happened was I was walking
out or doing something Caleb was just
like sitting on the couch and I started
laughing and he just pulled the camera
out so I didn't know it was there if it
had been there I don't know if I would
have been laughing like that right
though I think I'm getting better so I
think I think it's coming more quickly
now yeah and I think there is an
evolution in content I think I see a lot
of content creators go through this
where they make one style of content
because that's what they're comfortable
with like you get through these comfort
zone areas where it's like the first one
is like I'm gonna get on camera the
second one is like I'm gonna do this
thing regularly the third one is like oh
you actually want to hear my story like
you want to know like I want to know
Layla at 19 who was crazy and I'm like
oh I was that too you know and it really
it adds that relational piece without
having to be like incredibly Kardashian
where you're sharing every moment of
your life um and I think it is those
Comfort levels uh that people get to go
through
well I hope you enjoyed part one of my
exclusive interview with Layla hermosi I
had so many takeaways just from that
part and I'm excited to get into the
next part with you in our next episode
where we're going to be diving into
going from zero to a million what are
the struggles that happen in that season
what are some of the mindsets that you
have to overcome and some of her best
tips for new entrepreneurs coming on the
scene I'm so excited for you to get into
that make sure you go to
21videotips.com if you've not yet gone
there to get our video secrets that
we're not sharing anywhere else you can
get that free download and that free
masterclass with entrepreneurs like Gary
vaynerchuk Patrick Bet David Vanessa Lau
Alex hermosi and so many other
entrepreneurs you can get that at
21videotips.com thanks for listening or
watching today's episode hit the like
button if you're on YouTube hit the uh
subscribe button wherever you're taking
this content in and we'll catch it and
the next episode
[Music]